now we were talking about schools a lot
on the program with dominic raff with
mark drakeford and also of course with
professor spectra as well
the damage being done to children their
education and mental health by being out
of the classroom
is something that of course looks set to
continue for at least a few more weeks
in england now someone who wants to see
more done to address this is anna
longfield who's stepping down as
children's commissioner next month and
she joins us now thank you for being
on the program good morning um we're
just hearing that some quite positive
data from
the zoe app but also from the official
case data as well
that case numbers do seem to be coming
down do you think that schools could
reopen
sooner than the 8th of march in england
well i certainly hope
they can open as soon as possible
especially primary schools
and uh i think parents and indie
children
have their eyes on what is going to be
said at the uh press conference
in a few days time in terms of a roadmap
but also
whether their school will be opening on
the eighth this you know we should
remember that
most kids have been out of school for
just about a year they've just had a few
weeks back in
and of course during that time most have
been falling behind in their education
they've been away from their friends and
away from those support networks that
are just so
important to them especially those that
are more vulnerable
you said especially primary schools at
the beginning of your answer do you
think there is a case
to allow younger pupils to return before
secondary schools
well that's certainly something that um
countries across europe
have been doing um i mean the case is
that those children are less able to
work at home remotely
their their parents need to be there um
because they need a greater level of
care and support to learn
and they're much less likely to pick up
that level of infection
or indeed potentially transmit
so across europe you've got france
you've got italy you've got spain
all of whom have primary schools now
back open now of course there's exam
years as well that we need to
look at for older children but certainly
for primaries this seems to be a trend
that actually smaller entities can get
back open and can be managed
of course catching up on a year of
disrupted education
is going to be really very difficult and
what's it going to require
and do you think we should look at
things like shortening the school
holiday for example
to give a bit more time it's going to
take a huge
effort uh really this is kind of a war
effort
kind of scale um there needs of course
to be
a boost for children in terms of catch
up in education terms
in the classroom potentially as well
using some of those times
yes in school holidays the longer day
but part of that really needs to be as
well
about helping children to build back
those social skills
and that confidence you know they
haven't been in school but they haven't
been going to their football classes
either
they haven't been going to their karate
classes so all the
fabric of children's lives have
disappeared over
the last year so we need to see a really
ambitious program of recovery
with you know significant investment now
i think
from government i've always said
children haven't had their
nightingale moment yet and this is the
time because i think
the alternative is that there's a group
of children who won't
make up the time they've lost these are
the ones who started behind
who are struggling potentially about one
in six children
if they don't get that level of support
and boost they won't ever catch up
during their time at school and that's
something that
they and all of us will um uh you know
root the benefits
um or see the um see the impact of
yeah one in six children maybe not ever
catching up is really quite alarming
and i was also interested what you say
about the mental health aspect too
because it feels that we're very good at
picking apart the academic
impact of what the last year has been
but as you say there are
social impacts as well children spending
all day looking at screens
young children in particular being told
that they should be fearful of
close contact with other people what do
you think the consequences of this could
be
well we already had a significant mental
health
problem for most children in this
country from many children this country
salmon stevens called it an epidemic
only two years ago
but what we've had over the last year is
really you know the shock
of the pandemic but also that lack of
interaction with others
which at different ages has its impact
for very young children
i've had parents talk to me about how
their children have been come
clingy shy to talk to other children not
able to talk to other
children in the park um for primary
school each number that they were
worried about what the future would
bring you know all of the things they
expected to be around them and to be
stable in their lives has suddenly gone
and then of course
you know those that are in secondary
school and have their focus on exams and
what comes next
there are terrific number of uh
uncertainties for those children so we
know the prevalence
again is one in six for those children
as well in terms of
probable mental health conditions i'd
like to see
mental health teams in and around every
school to really help children
at the first instance before it falls
into crisis
the education secretary gavin
williamson's had a lot of criticism
about the way that he's handled
the pandemic what do you make of his
performance
well look i have left who sits around
the cabinet table very much the prime
minister
and of course it's been a difficult year
with a lot
um to cope with but i don't need to tell
you that they have been
difficulties over the last year and
schools themselves would be the first to
say that
um i'm pleased that the prime minister
is taking a lead on this
i'm pleased that the emphasis now and
that commitment is
to put children and put in schools at
the heart of the
opening up of the economy and opening up
of the country
and i think that's where it needs to be
because it's much more complex than
just what goes on in schools a whole
range of factors need to be in place
to ensure that schools open and that now
must be the priority
and just finally research by the joseph
rowntree foundation this week has found
that over four million children
living in poverty one million of them
under the age of given this would you
like to see the 20 pound a week
uplift to universal credit extended
yes i think it does need to be extended
it's had an important impact and that
needs to continue
this isn't the time for families to have
that uncertainty
or that drop in income and what we do
know with very young children that
clearly
are bearing some of the brunt of that
increase in poverty
if you fall behind before you get to
school you have very few chances
to catch up during your school day so
the impact of
on a child's life throughout so it is so
important i think it's
clear now we have a problem with poverty
in this country
we really need a long-term plan as part
of that buildback
to ensure that all children can flourish
and all cam families can give their
children
the support they want to okay anne
longfield thank you so much for
coming on the program this morning thank
you